what has to happen in the first 10
minutes of a horror screenplay
i think it depends on the genre
and what you're trying to accomplish
but i think certainly
there should be something that happens
in that first 10 minutes that makes an
audience realize holy crap i'm in for a
ride
something has to happen in that first 10
minutes that gives you that feeling and
if that doesn't happen i i
i will oftentimes wonder what we we're
waiting on
that's just like some a friend of mine
he gets onto me because he's way bigger
filming tv buff than i am
and
he always says to me like oh you stopped
watching the tv show too soon it got
really good on the fifth episode and i'm
like then why did they wait into the
fifth episode
do it from the beginning
i do this for a living you can do it
do it from the beginning i think it
works the same way with with horror
films if in the first 10 minutes you've
you've not told the audience what kind
of ride they're on
then you in my book you haven't
succeeded in my book you're setting
yourself up to fail
so in the first 10 minutes give them
something give them something to realize
holy crap something's about to go down
so it doesn't necessarily have to be
um a gory scene it's just maybe a sense
of mystery a sense of something
ominous that's looming
yeah i just i mean give them some that's
why i say depends on the type of film
that it is
because there can be it can be a film
that is going to make you feel so
uncomfortable so they give you something
at the beginning to let you know
like what's happening or what the stakes
are or something something that really
pulls you in and lets you know like i
really need to keep watching this film
if you haven't given them the hook like
what's gonna pull them in i don't i
don't know what you're doing really and
that goes really not even just for for
horror films but films in general
i think you should give somebody some
indication of of what kind of ride
they're on
is it going to be the the disney teacups
that spin around is it going to be you
know space mountain what kind of ride
are we on you know
so with 70s and 80s horror you think we
took our time really
making it a little more eerie a little
more suspenseful
i think
people cared more
there is
there's this thing that happens when you
shoot film where everybody goes hey this
is serious you know
and
i feel
that's lost now
i feel like people say you know if we
don't get it right we'll get it again
we'll do it again and we'll do it again
we'll do it again nobody takes it really
is serious but even right now if you
tell somebody we're shooting 35
millimeter film and you show up and you
plop down the film camera everybody goes
hey hey this is serious
and everybody starts taking way more i
don't know what it is about a film
camera that makes everything more
serious
but it does
and i think back then that was all you
had you only had film it was just what
kind of film are you gonna shoot with
but you only had film
and so everybody took everything very
serious and and then two if you were a
small production you had a limited
amount of film
most of the time you were shooting with
a bunch of short ends whatever
it was very serious and it was very well
thought out and nothing was shot in an
extraneous sense
nothing was shot just in case everything
was shot with a purpose
and uh
you know i think we're missing that
today
is that why you love the 80s horror
genre oh
i love it for so many reasons but that's
one of them
that's one of them um i certainly i felt
there was a magic in the 80s you know i
felt i mean it came in at the late 70s
as well but but there was just a certain
magic with the 80s and the way the films
entertained while still taking it all
very seriously
and and still really focusing on on the
creative and technical aspects but just
really putting that production value out
there making it feel magical making it
feel special um
i i feel like that's
that's something that i i've carried
with me in in all of my films trying to
make something special
always
even when it's a shoestring budget i've
tried to find some sort of way
are there five 80s horror films or late
70s horror films that you think every
horror filmmaker should watch like
you know salem's lot or or you know any
of these stephen king
um
i mean
my favorite is one that
you know when people hear it they kind
of go what is that but
uh evil dead trap i think everybody
should see that i want to say it was i
don't know when that one came out i know
it was in the
mid to late 80s
and
it is a completely insane horror film
from japan
and it was at a time when those movies
were banned especially ones that were
this that depicted violence and gore to
this extent i mean this guy
went hard
core
okay
and i remember seeing that in where did
i see that film i don't even know where
i saw it it's such such a rare film i
forget where i saw it but i fell in love
with it immediately and i've watched it
i don't know how many times i had to buy
it and the only way you could buy it in
the u.s
was part of a a big pack of films where
it was evil dead trap because that's the
only one i really really watch and then
it was another one called like entrails
of a virgin
oh yeah yeah um it's just
they're so bizarre
but yet you could tell when the film is
made it's made with love
this guy loved the genre
he loved this was before gore gross out
was a thing
before you know gore it was you know
people think about like the mutilator
that movie and
which
not a great movie but the thing about it
was was you know it had some decent gore
and the positions that they put people
in even when they didn't show it when it
was just implied you were like ah you
know
um but nobody had taken it to the extent
that this guy did
you know i think his name is was it
toshi toshiharu ikeda is his name
and uh the visuals of that movie are
just so disturbing
um
but
i look at that film as being my top
horror film
uh
ones that influenced me yes
now if you start getting into others
that people should see
do you mean like top hard top just films
in general
just because it just seemed like there
was a creepiness factor that really took
time to build yeah and and i really love
that of the that era not so much the
gore yeah absolutely this one had this
one had the gore came in much later
but it did have the creepy effect
speaking of evil dead trap it did it if
you haven't seen it please see it it's
i endorse this film okay my name is
josten yes and i approve this message um
now if you're if you're moving away from
that you have to like right next to that
put halloween the original halloween now
that one is not 80s that one's late 70s
i think that's like 78 or 79.
um
but that's what i meant by late 70s
early 80s you know that time period so i
would definitely put halloween on that
list i think they they got busy quick
they let you knew let they let you know
what type of movie you were in uh they
had a summer camp feel but in someone's
house which was pretty easy i mean
pretty interesting i i really loved that
about the film um i think he took his
time
and he didn't try to rush anything in
the film but you understood in that
first 10 minutes what kind of movie you
were watching it wasn't a mystery it
wasn't a mystery
um i think once you once you leave that
one
i want to i want to stay more
in the more accessible range so i would
say if i if i'm going with what's more
accessible i would then lean towards
your uh your hell razors i think
hellraiser was very creative for his
time
um
i don't think anybody really kind of got
into that aspect yet of making your
making who would normally be a villain
kind of an anti-hero
so i thought that was pretty cool that
was pretty clever
um
and from there i jump into to your your
jason's and your freddy krueger's
yeah
what about the use i don't know if this
would be horror tropes but you know
let's say the the late night phone call
and no one's there yeah like what what
are some of the things that are just
tried and true that they always work it
doesn't matter
what year this is just it just builds an
intrigue
um i think that shot from behind
when a person is walking through a house
and the camera is drifting behind them
and they stop and the camera's slowly
getting closer
okay because you're like oh my god
what's gonna happen you know i think
that always works and that never gets
old and nobody ever says why you know
that's tired nobody ever says that
because it's just the movement of a
camera i think once you get into actions
that's where it gets
you know kind of tropey
i think when you get into the late night
phone call i think when you get into the
um oh my gosh it's so hot let me take my
clothes off and then you see the hand
reach in and take the clothes away and
it's like oh
that's not the killer that's their
friend you know it's just like oh come
on you know like a lot of those things i
i think they get really tropey but i
think the
the camera tricks are the things that
don't get old i don't like the jumpy
things i don't really like those so much
those are boring to me mainly because i
don't jump but um
i i like to be creeped out i like to
end the movie and
like go should i turn off the light you
know yeah i want that feeling you know
um
but i think
the whole camera moving behind someone i
love rosemary's baby when the camera
kind of shifts a little
and you're constantly thinking
something's about to happen to her just
because the camera moved a little i like
little subtle things like that
i think those are still very effective
they'll never go away
should something scary happen on page
one of a horror film or is it better to
wait a little bit
if it fits the story
it's all about what fits the story
and what story you're trying to tell
if um
if you get right to it on page one hey
bravo i hope that you don't take your
foot off the gas cause
now you've built up expectation
because i think you said in the last
question that halloween they let you
know fairly quickly
what was going on
is that something that did they maintain
it it's been a while sorry so oh yeah
but but mainly because halloween wasn't
it wasn't a story about a guy in a mask
who was just killing people
at random like that wasn't the story
um it was a story of evil and evil
started young
and this kid was full of evil
and so
as he when he grew up and he came home
it was like what is this guy going to do
now
you know and he was stalking jamie lee's
curtis character and you always knew it
was that it was that that sense of did
you ever see uh what was that movie uh
it follows
and it was you know
the girl
has sex with the guy and then
the evil spirit starts following her and
if it catches her it'll kill her that
sort of thing right
so the thing about it was it moved slow
but it was always present and it was
always closing in so even if it was far
behind
you knew you had to stay that much ahead
of it right you knew
in this movie jamie lee curtis didn't
know only the audience knew
that he was closing in on her he's
getting closer and closer and close and
that's where the dread came from that's
why in the beginning of the film
when we see him as a kid and we see him
like he's actually going about murdering
you know his sister and the sister's
boyfriend and all that stuff
it was the build up of this evil that
was inside this kid and he slowly worked
his way up to that in those first 10
minutes right
and then he grew up and now you're
watching it play out as an adult so he
he built he set the tone for what the
rest of the film was going to be and he
didn't really let up all he did was give
you someone to care about in jamie lee
curtis's character laurie strode he gave
you somebody to care about and then he
said now watch me butcher her and then
you were like you were so worried about
it you were like please
run he's right there you know
and i think he did that very very well
sure and it would be the same i guess in
the exorcist as well even though the
character wasn't stalking her it was
inside of her and she couldn't she
couldn't get it out she couldn't stop it
yeah
you set the tone very early with that
one i mean they said an eerie tone uh
when they were digging up they're
excavating the thing and it was it just
felt weird the musical cues the zooms
all of it felt weird all of it felt very
very weird and they kept that feeling
throughout it just kept you off balance
it kept you really off balance it made
your skin crawl a little bit
right yeah it was great